i i uh head up customer success here at
red panda and we'll be talking about
graviton and arm and uh how that
compares to x86
so
just a a quick sort of overview of what
we'll be covering um we'll talk a little
bit about the gravel on story and where
that originated from
a little bit about red panda and you
know what is red panda and why is this
interesting in the context of the
comparison between the two different
architectures
red panda is written in c plus so we'll
talk about some of the implications of
that and also the thread per core model
that we have within red panda um and how
that affects things uh we'll also then
we'll get into the benchmarking of arm
versus x86 talk about conclusions and
then have any uh you know answer any
questions that might come up at the end
so with that
um let's talk a little bit about
graviton uh you know amazon
you know we've all used arm processors
if we have a mobile device so we all
have some familiarity with uh you know
with arm chips or you know raspberry
pi's and other things from that
perspective but uh amazon sort of first
started with graviton in 2018 and these
were pretty you know it was interesting
to see what they were doing in 2018 they
were the performance was still kind of
in the early stages uh and very quickly
after the initial launch graviton 2 came
out a year later which was actually a 50
performance improvement on the original
graviton launch
a few things that are different with arm
versus
what we typically get with intel
instances inside of aws
is that every core is a physical core
inside of arm so when you know when
we're seeing something that says v cores
or other things like that um you know in
the
instance uh information for
these graviton instances you know these
are actual physical pores and they're
not a hyper threaded core like we're
typically are uh used to when we're
looking at the intel instances where you
know two hyperthreaded cores is giving
us a full physical core
this you know all of this was pretty
interesting to us as a company um as you
know as red panda as we're you know very
focused on performance and also cost of
performance
i'm but we didn't really get interested
into this space until uh aws just
recently launched in november 2021
they're storage optimized instances uh
previous to that you know the storage
that was actually attached to these
graviton instances was either very small
or you were relying upon uh ebs
and persisted disk which it comes with
its own kind of performance impact and
sort of cost along with that as well so
i'm but you know in november 2021 and a
few different instances were uh
you know were actually uh introduced
that you know added a large amount of
storage to the systems and those are
going to be the instances that we're
really going to be focusing on today
graviton 3 also
is just
was just released last month uh and they
first showed up in the c7g instances
and we're interested in seeing what what
that sort of does in the additional
performance that you know we might get
out of those instances or out of this
graviton 3 architecture but um
you know they haven't made their way
into the storage optimized instances
just quite yet so you know typically
this is a pretty you know uh
similar thing that amazon does across
multiple instances where they start with
like the compute or the compute optimize
instances first and then eventually move
them down into general and then into
also the storage optimized so you know
we expect later this year we'll start
seeing them show up in these storage
size instances as well
so what instances are you know do we
have available to us that are really you
know
focused on this storage optimization
and it really comes down to the im4gn
instances and the is4
uh gen instances
and you can see that you know you're
getting a large amount of storage uh on
a per instance basis really the
difference between the you know the the
two different instance types or base
instance types is the amount of cores
that you're getting for this storage and
also uh memory the other key thing is
really the networking too as well you
know we can see the im4gns you know we
we are getting
um you know you're you're at the four
extra large uh you're
you're able to uh you know how
guaranteed networking and you're able to
go you know a fair bit higher all the
way up to 100 gigabits per second
whereas with the is 4g ends you know
this is more focused with uh you know
workloads that might be less cpu
intensive but still have a requirement
for a lot of local storage so
you know really just a ratio change from
you know from one side to the other
and
you know just to quickly touch upon the
x86 side of things um and the different
types of uh process
instant sites that we're going to be
using there uh we'll talk very very
briefly about i3 um you know this is the
i3 instances for some of the early
storage optimized instances
amazon uh
you know had introduced uh these are
based on broadwell and introduced back
in 2017.
we'll be doing most of our comparisons
against the i3en which is sky lake or
cascade lake um and these were back in
2019 these are kind of the default
instances that you know we run red panda
on um
you know pretty regularly and you know a
lot of different databases uh you know
typically default to i3en
um and also a number of different you
know storage heavy uh applications you
know typically rely upon that
i have also done a we have a little bit
of a comparison with the i4i instances
which are ice lake introduced this year
uh these are kind of interesting you
know the performance at least from an i
o perspective is pretty amazing um you
know there are some downsides to the i4i
instances and i'll talk about that as we
get a little bit further in the
presentation but then the other thing to
really kind of take note is that you
know as i was mentioning earlier on the
arms side
you know we're going to see bcpu's and
that's a hyper-threading core or a
hyper-threaded core that we're going to
get so you know we're not talking so
it's always interesting doing this
comparison of you know we're talking a
comparison of cores to hyper-threaded
cores uh in you know when we're
comparing the instance types
and you know just to kind of quickly
touch upon like what we have there you
know we can see the i4i instances we
actually are a little you know the
storage ratio is a little bit lower um
you know we're getting probably half the
size as what we would see with the i4
uh
or the is4 instances um
but you know you can you know with the
i4i instances you know we are you know
getting uh
the aws nitro systes and then looking at
the i3en instances you know we have more
storage per instance um but it is using
kind of a slower chip or kind of a last
generation
cpu architecture
and
you know we are getting uh the disks are
a bit slower in comparison to the i4i
instances
so before we start really digging into
the benchmark itself um you probably
have the question of you know if you're
not familiar with red panda probably one
of your questions is you know what is
red panda and why am i wearing a shirt
with a lot of red pandas on it um so
what panda is is it's a streaming data
platform uh and it's fully kafka api
compatible so if you're familiar with
kafka you've run any kind of kafka
workloads
or you know run anything against the
kafk api uh red panda can actually uh be
a drop-in replacement for kafka for
those particular workloads now
where we differ in kafka is you know we
are
really focused on modern hardware uh so
you know we're fully written in ski plus
plus uh making use of a you know number
of optimizations and things like you
know making use of xfs it's a file
system for you know doing out of order
rights and pre-allocation
we're really focused on low latency in
comparison to you know kafka is
typically really focused on higher
throughput we can do high throughput but
we can also do low latency 2 as well
and we're able to do this typically with
a large reduction in overall hardware
we have uh we're much simpler to use or
pretty pretty simple to use platform a
single binary so you know easy to get
this up and running or to deploy it
yourself also to run it locally within
your system you know no external
dependencies at all so you don't have to
run this with uh you know any sort of
like xcd or zookeeper or anything from
that standpoint
we also really focus on doing uh fsyncs
after every batch of messages so this is
where you know these types of instances
are very interesting to us because they
handle a large amount of iops uh and so
you know we can actually do iops very
quickly uh you know your your sort of
p50th latency on these types of iops or
you know within the microseconds versus
you know persistent storage could be in
the mic uh in the milliseconds so you
know for us like this these types of uh
benchmarks and doing these performance
comparisons is really critical for us
and you know we also do use raft behind
the scenes uh so we are a raft-based
system so this allows us to write out
you know partial failures
of an environment and also provides more
predictable performance and other
replication mechanisms as this allows us
to have you know one slow uh follower in
the system and not have that affect the
overall replication and latency of the
the system itself
the one other key thing that we have
inside of red panda that is uh you know
makes us scale or makes this possible
for us to scale
on modern work or modern machines is
something called cdstar
so steezar is a framework uh it's a you
know a framework and library uh that's
fully written in c plus plus it provides
a um
you know really kind of an async
programming model so you can kind of
think of this as you know this was sort
of uh put out there before i o urine was
uh you know really sort of popular uh
and you know we get that question quite
often of like how does c star compare
with i o urine uh you know they are very
similar in many ways but
uh this allows us to do things like
futures and promises the other thing
that this provides us is the ability to
do a thread per core architecture
where
what red panda does is that when it
first starts up on a system it will look
to see how many cores we have available
and then it will spin out that many
threads and we'll pin a thread to a
given core so this eliminates any kind
of locking or global locks that occur
because we're pretty much treating every
core as if it's its own system in a way
um this minimizes any sort of i o
blocking
and reduces overall context switching
that you might have within the system so
this works really well with arm because
you know we are getting physical cores
and we're not being you know we're not
on a hyper-threaded core that that might
potentially be context switched as well
so
this type of architecture actually lends
itself quite well to the arm um you know
to the arm
type of deployment
and just to kind of show like you know
some of the uh you know that we are
performance oriented this is some of the
benchmarking that we've done previously
with uh kafka in comparison to red panda
uh this was running on a three node i3
en 6 extra large instances doing 500
megabytes per second
and you know as you can see red panda's
around two you know two three
milliseconds of latency on average uh in
our tell latencies you stay very
consistent all the way up to the end uh
in comparison to kafka which know kafka
if you're not familiar with is all java
based um so it has a
little bit of a more challenging time
fully optimizing i o or doing fast i o
um so you know there
you can see that kind of goes through on
the latency side of things where we're
seeing an increase in overall latency
and an increase in the overall tail
latencies in the system
and you know with those types of
optimizations and being able to have
this reduced amount of latency this
really
helps us reduce the overall footprint of
red pandas so i you know we've had many
instances where people have gone been
able to go from 50 node kafka clusters
to seven node red panda clusters uh just
because of the optimizations that
we
in my apologies my computer decided to
um
to take me out of presentation mode uh
where we have seen that uh you know
we've been able to reduce the amount of
um
the amount of infrastructure really
needed
for uh
you know for kafka to red panda where
we're able to reduce the number of nodes
and with this reduction you know we
bring down the overall cost of running a
system like this and also you reduce the
overall amount of infrastructure and
power needed for a a system like this to
be able to do the same exact workload
with better latencies
so enough about red panda let's get into
the meat of things but you know i wanted
to give that kind of context of why uh
you know we would really care about this
and why you would look at using red
panda as um you know something for
investigating you know how graviton
instance types work in comparison to x86
but first before we could actually do
that you know we had to also uh
port our c plus code over to arm
um so to make that work
you know redband is fully written in c
plus plus you know we thought for sure
as we were going through this exercise
last year you know we were going to have
to add some macros to the code or you
know do some specific things to make
this work but all we ended up having to
do was to really just change the
architecture uh that was used to
actually compile the code so we changed
it from uh you know going with uh amd 64
to just arm v8 um and
this we just worked out of the box with
actually no code changes to needed on
the c plus side
what also really helped here is that we
vendor all our third-party dependencies
and build them ourselves so c-star as i
was mentioning earlier we actually
vendor that uh specifically and build
c-star as kind of part of the build
process for red pandas so
we're able to you know recompile all the
libraries and all the dependencies
into uh onto the arm framework and just
make this work seamlessly
cool
so
now getting into the kind of the
benchmarking so what did we look at you
know we wanted to do data intensive uh
data intensive workloads and show the
demands that that puts on both the disc
and the network so we actually tested a
few different areas um and it says three
but it's actually four but we focus on
this bandwidth we focus on adjusting
throughput bandwidth uh regulation which
or regulator behavior which i'll talk
about in a little detail at the very end
which was kind of an interesting oddity
that we saw and then also into in
latency as well as you know it's always
good to sort of focus on you know what
does this actually look like when we're
talking in latency in a system and the
two system the two ones that we really
focused on from an instance type is the
i3n that i mentioned the is4 gn as well
so without further ado let's get into
what the results for this look like
so
the first ones uh you know we we did the
disc bandwidth to see you know what
could we possibly get from a bytes you
know gigabytes per second
um standpoint so i
you know first off we just used fio
so just doing something as simple as uh
you know 16 kilobyte block sizes so uh
you know that is critical to note uh red
panda itself uh our system the reason
why we go 16 kilobyte block sizes is
that that's typically the amount of data
that we persist on a per i o operation
uh we um you know we chunk our data into
16 kilobyte writes so you know doing
this kind of gives us a pretty good
comparison of what it's going to do when
it you know we're running red panda on
the system
doing direct i o and then using libaio
uh for the i o engine for this and then
also making sure that we keep the i o
depth uh you know the the buffer is full
as we go through this as that's
something that's also done inside of
panda for further optimization
so you can see here that you know the i3
and 12 extra large is about equivalent
to the is4 gen eight extra large
uh and you know the comparison down the
line is pretty similar as we start to
get into some of the smaller instances
we can see that the i3 en
instances do pull out a little bit more
but you know you are also you have more
cores in those machines
in comparison to the is4gns
for the amount of data that you have but
once we actually move up into some of
the larger instances uh you know we can
absolutely see that you know they're
very equivalent with the amount of data
or the gigabytes per second that can be
put through on those instance types
so the next test that we did is that we
actually installed red panda on the
different nodes um and then we used the
tool from librd kafka which is kind of
the de facto or one of the de facto
kafka libraries out there today it's a c
plus library that's used by or behind
the scenes by a number of different um
uh drivers out there whether you're
using like a python driver or other
things from that perspective
and
they actually have a tool within liberty
kafka code rd kafka performance they can
do
you can do throughput or producing to
the machine so we had we were just doing
producing to these systems so we're just
producing data do it to it using client
machines that were c6 i8 extra large
instances using a one kilobyte message
size
so you know this chart looks very
similar to our previous chart there's
not a huge amount of difference you know
we're talking about maybe a couple uh
you know hundreds of megabytes uh if
that when it comes you know in the
comparison between these systems so you
know not a huge amount of comparison
difference between the two
but when things get where things get a
lot more interesting for us is when we
actually start to look at the cost
factor to this
so
the way that we did this was we actually
uh looked at gigabytes per second for
hours
per dollar so how you know how much
gigabytes per second can i get on a per
instance basis per the cost of that
instance itself
and when i look at when we look at it
from that perspective we see that the
is4gns have quite the advantage here um
you know they're able to uh you know to
get us about a 20 better value in
comparison to the i3dn instances
so you know this is this is pretty
fantastic to be able to see a 20
improvement uh you know from a cost
perspective and still be able to get the
same level of performance uh you know is
uh is pretty phenomenal
the other thing that we saw through some
of our testing so we were also testing
on some i3 instances and looking at some
smaller instances you know we're always
interested in how small individual or
you know how small of an instance can we
run red panda on
as we have customers that run us in sort
of iot devices or edge devices where
they only have one core available or
other things from that perspective
and so you know we did some testing on
the smallest instances the i3 large
um and also on the is 4g and large and
one of the things that we noticed was
that
there was a
kind of a
smoothing of throughput over this system
this should actually be timed down here
not gigabytes per second per dollar but
um what you can see is that this is the
amount of data that was able to be
pushed through
and
we see with the i3 large instances that
this spikes at times and then just drops
down to zero and where with the is4gn
there was a better regulation or kind of
you know regulator smoothing uh that was
happening uh within the environment that
allowed for a more consistent uh uh
throughput of that system so you know
providing sort of a more consistent
performance uh versus you know sort of
the spiky behavior uh that we saw with
uh you know some of the other smaller
instances specifically the i3 large
instance
there are also other factors to consider
here you know we are mostly focused on
in this particular benchmark
storage and you know really sort of
network and you know we can look at the
different instance types of like what
are we paying when it comes or you know
what is the value that we're getting
from like the amount of uh vcpus and you
know this makes it a little challenging
because you know for the is4gns vcpus is
the same as cores uh which is not the
case on the i3en instances and we can
also see like you know what are we
getting from a value perspective for uh
the amount of gigabytes per dollar that
that is spent
uh or for the you know sort of the cost
factor that's spent and also for memory
and for uh network
and in this comparison you know larger
numbers are better um because that means
that we're getting more for our money uh
versus you know the smaller number is uh
you know
a bit less so what we're what we see
across the board is that for the is4gn
instances
we have 17 additional ssd capacity
18 more guaranteed network capacity um
you know we are getting a bit more
memory uh
on the i3en instances and we are also
getting a bit more uh from a vcpu
perspective but you know the the things
that really focus or that are really
critical for us in our systems is
network and disk uh and for streaming
systems that's typically the the case so
you know this is actually a great sort
of outcome for us um for a system like
red panda
so now on to end to end latency
so using the same system that are kind
of the same benchmarking tool that i was
mentioning earlier the open messaging
benchmark
you know this is a
a framework that is used for doing
comparisons of different stream
processing engines so you know if you're
comparing a um
you know rabbit mq to kafka
or to
pulsar you know open messaging benchmark
you know it is a linux foundation
project i would highly recommend take a
look at it we have our own fork within
um
red panda as well that just has uh you
know the specific red panda drivers and
deployment scripts and things like that
inside of it that you can take a look at
as well uh instead of our github repo
but
i wanted to do a uh we also wanted to do
a benchmark of just what the in latency
would look like for a few different
instance types
so going across the board i kind of
wanted to stay right around the thousand
dollar per
node cost basis uh this is the you know
cost for running inside of
us east 2 um with
just doing on demand with no sort of
cost savings or anything from that
perspective and this is a one
node monthly price uh on a per instance
basis here so i wanted to look at the
i4i's because i found them kind of
interesting you know they are sort of uh
yeah a number of uh you know redis and
cilla db had been referenced as talking
about their their performance and some
of the benchmarks that they had done on
it so you know really kind of focused on
the the high uh i o uh
space and then also bringing in the
import gn and then the is4 gn2 extra
large and then the i3 en 3 extra large
which is what we compared uh you know in
a similar fashion to the is4 gn2 extra
large
and we can see here they're all pretty
comparable in price the is4gn2 extra
large is definitely you know the
cheapest option and we can see that you
know the im4 gm fortune large is a
little bit more expensive than our i3n3
extra large but
one of the key things to note here is
it's a guaranteed 25 gigabits per second
of networking
which is pretty fantastic for
aws um whenever you see up to 25
gigabits per second in aws uh what my
experience has been is that that
typically means you can get 25 gigabits
per second for you know around eight to
ten minutes and then you get throttled
anywhere between eight to twelve
gigabits per second uh for the remainder
of the hour so you know it you have to
always do your testing with iperf and
other things from that perspective to
fully understand what this really means
um but it is always great when you can
have this guaranteed amount of
networking throughput so you can take
that guessing game out of you know is it
the network am i running out of credits
on my network
connection and you know not having to
use that as or have that as another
point of investigation for these systems
so what does this look like so this is
the output from the open messaging
benchmark we were running a workload of
750 megabytes per second of throughput
one kilobyte message size i had two
client machines running so two m five
and four extra larges and here you know
this is the average in latency of the
system
um
we um
you know for uh the eye for eye
instances you can see that you know that
provided us the best overall performance
i'm and then you know the second uh sort
of the second contender in there was the
im4gn instance
where you're pretty pretty close uh and
you know these this was a test that was
run for uh an hour or we ran these you
know all the tests for an hour uh you
know we can see that it's pretty
very close to what we saw with the i4i
instances
i
and then also the i3 e and three extra
large uh you know is uh is in third
place here and then the is4 gn two extra
large uh you know comes out still in a
pretty good respectable latency overall
but you know definitely um it you know
suffers a little bit based upon the fact
that you know we have reduced number of
of course in comparison to the other
systems so and one thing to kind of
really note here too uh going back to
the instance types and what we just saw
from you know the overall performance is
you know the i4i gives us the best
performance
but only has half the amount of storage
in comparison to all the rest of the
instances
so um you know even though it can uh the
storage is pretty amazing and some of
the testing i did on the storage i was
able to you know for this instance type
the i4ri for extra large i was able to
see 120 000 iops
per second
uh or uh yeah 120 000 iops on a single
drive there and also two gigabytes per
second of throughput which is amazing
but the challenge with that is that the
network couldn't keep up with the actual
drive performance so you know having a
system where you might be very i o
intensive but not have to do a lot of
network i o you know the ifries are very
interesting in that regard but you know
for red panda itself and for other
systems where you are uh focusing on
both disk and network you know the im4gn
in this case um you know really does
well and as a you know as a great
contender
also it's really important to look at
what the end
percentile latencies are kind of uh you
know what what the tail latencies of the
system look like
so we can see here that you know the i4i
and the im4gn
are pretty you know are pretty much neck
and neck in that regard and we see a
little bit higher latencies with the i3
en 3 extra large and then the highest
latencies with the is4 gn2 extra-large
and that's to be expected as you know we
have half the cores in the is-4g and two
extra-large in comparison to the ion you
know im4gn if we go back to here we can
see it's even uh you know we have half
of the amount of cores from one system
to the other in the comparison of the
two
so what does this really tell us this
tells us that you know the im4g and
forge large yet provides a great balance
between sort of performance and cost and
overall storage capability um
and then the i4i instance is interesting
uh you know we
it is something that we'll probably you
know ourselves here at red panda we'll
do a bit more investigation into because
for cases where you know we want to have
the highest amount of i o throughput and
then maybe age out data to something
like s3 or to an object store uh you
know the ifri instances might make sense
but again you know it always goes back
to
network i o so you know if we're doing
operations back to s3 we might cut into
our network and then might not be able
to even take full advantage of what's
available from a disk perspective so you
know if you're running database
operations where there's compactions and
other things happening quite often the
i4i instance might make sense
but you know in general it you know you
might not be able to actually make full
use of the i o available of the disks
themselves uh if you can't drive it
enough from a networking standpoint
and then the im 4g n forager larges you
know we have that seven terabytes of
disk space for 1065 per month
uh in comparison to uh you know the i4i
forest largest where it's just you know
half the amount of storage um for you
know about a thousand dollars a month so
you know it kind of you know always
interesting to sort of see the
difference of you know what are you
going to get from a price performance
standpoint and the um you know the
overall outcome of what that looks like
when you're actually looking at the inta
and latency of the system itself
so what
you know what are our conclusions and
how do we you know how do we summarize
all this at the end of the day
so as we saw in some of the earlier
tests you know the arm instances have
that 20 advantage in price performance
um you know we see smoother regulations
on the smaller instances so you know i
think it's really clear that for these
smaller instances running with the arm
processes or the arm processor is you
know is absolutely a great way to go uh
as you get you know sort of more
predictable performance and uh you know
you're getting a pretty a pretty good
ratio of price and performance with
those smaller instances so you know if i
was running any kind of smaller
workloads i would really look to to run
that on arm today
and then the im4gn4x large provides a
great price performance comparison for
end to end latency and you know the i4i
instances are still relatively new uh
you know still worth a little more
investigation um but you know definitely
some concerns there that they're not
enough network to really help or to
really drive the uh you know the full
amount of
i o that's available on those systems so
so with that i'll take a quick look on
um
you know what some of the questions are
uh
so all one of the questions is you know
are we what kind of aws storage instance
types are we using
uh they are all ssd nbme backed so we we
didn't want to
um
we didn't really want to look at uh any
http based back systems uh because we
were you know really kind of focused on
like what we could do or what could we
drive from a
i o perspective and
uh you know you're gonna get the best i
o and the best latencies from using
local nvme ssd storage
we do use
gcc for compiling uh
i in well we have multiple different
ways in which we can compile red panda
uh you know llvm and ceiling is is one
of them um you know we do have more
information if you actually go to our
github repo you can find how exactly
where uh you know how to compile red
panda it is repanda itself is a source
available so you can go and download it
and compile it locally and you know we
have all the build scripts within the uh
within the repo itself
so the features of the arm processors
that contributed to the ingestion
throughput results you know if what we
saw was that
you know we didn't really we didn't do a
huge amount of performance comparison on
what we could do or you know what we saw
from a io or sorry a cpu perspective but
what we wanted to really uh compare was
you know were
were we
yeah the amount of cpu that we had
available for being able to drive the
full amount of i o
because you know for us what's really
critical is to make sure that we have
enough i o
or enough cpu processing to be able to
drive the i o of the system and that was
really the the key thing that we saw
with this is that you know what was that
what was that uh you know
of the arm architecture
uh
and these arm instances provided by
amazon
you know what best uh sort of you know
throughput and network i o could we get
and that was really the the point of
this comparison to really see uh you
know what could we see in comparison to
sort of the standard intel instances and
you know as uh the conclusion as was i
was showing is that you we can
absolutely drive the i o and network
with the number of cores that are
available there uh you know typically
it's being done with less amount of
cores and that provides us you know that
20
um
sort of value savings over what we see
with intel so you know we're able to um
you know get consistent performance that
can drive full i o optimization of these
instances
so
there's a question around uh with the
bandwidth regulator is this uh
this seems to be something that was
added as part of the graviton two
instances there wasn't a huge amount
of information really presented by aws
of what was happening in this regard
this was more just an observation that
we had made in the systems of you know
the comparison of what we saw with the
i3 large instances and with aws you know
as anyone who's done performances in aws
uh realizes is that a lot of times it's
a bit of a guessing game understanding
you know what exactly is happening
behind the scenes am i running into you
know am i running out of credits for the
particular network um
you know network for the particular
instance that i'm running on or
you know how are they splitting up a ssd
disk across multiple
uh instances because if we go back and
look at
sort of the the in the earlier part of
the presentation
and look at some of these instance types
i you know especially for like the i3 en
uh uh i3 en instances you know your
standard drive is 7.5 terabytes
so when we're looking at these really
small instances you know we're having
that drive be split up across multiple
uh instances and at that point you know
there has to be
some type of regulation in place to you
know not allow you to make full use of
you know all the i o capabilities of
that underlined device and have it be
split up evenly across multiple tenants
or multiple instances for making up that
drive so
you know uh aws does a number of kind of
different tricks behind the scenes to
try to help with that and we just saw
that in general um you know the
in the arm instances especially the
smaller arm instances where there is
a uh you know sharing of the underlying
drive across multiple instances that
this regulation was much smoother than
what we saw with some of the other
older instances so it's hard to say what
that's exactly attributed to but just
something to be aware of as you run on
these types of instances inside of aws
great
i think that's all the questions that i
see here
uh at the end
um you know if there's any further
questions about uh about red panda and
what we've done here you know feel free
to come and uh join our slack channel
you know ask questions there
we have a pretty you know active slack
community uh you can always reach out to
us and we're happy to share a little bit
more details around panda and some of
the testing that we've done on the
different instance types we also have uh
this actually a lot of this data came
from a blog post uh that you'll find on
our website too as well where we have uh
you know a lot of this information
published in a blog format uh that you
can check out after the fact that i
think uh is also being posted in the
uh in the chat as well so you can take a
look at
and uh yeah um that's uh that concludes
uh this webinar for me and uh thank you
so much for your time and for your
questions and uh i appreciate uh your
attention
thank you so much roko for your time
today and thank you everyone for joining
us as a reminder this recording will be
on the linux foundation youtube page
later today we hope you join us for
future webinars have a wonderful day